RULES COMMITTEE IS ORDER.
ISSUED BY SEVEN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
P. MAVENS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
AMERICA SECTOR BECAUSE CULTURAL
BELIEFS.
HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
TORONTO THERE.
FRIEDMAN.
GRAYSON HERE. DAIS BECAUSE IT.
AND THERE AND
PRESIDENT SALAS SON WALDRON NOW
HAVE A.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVEN'T
CONSENT AGENDA.
S. CONSISTS OF MAYBE TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE RETROGRADE RELATED
LEGISLATIVE ETHICS.
I HARASSMENT EDUCATION
NO I DON'T. LIKE MOVEMENT
SECONDED.
UNDER CENTERPIECE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY.
I COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
I CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE MAYES AYE
AYE MAYES AYE NAZARIAN BY THIS
AREA AYE SALAS AYE SALAS AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE.
MOST JUST PASSED INDUSTRIAL
STRANGER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH